so we've just done the differentiate now
comes part two hence and that word is
really important whenever you see it in
an HSC question it means you must use
the thing that you just did sometimes
you'll get hints or otherwise which
means here's a clue but you can do it
however way you'd like when you see
hints and no other qualification your
next line pretty much has to use this
right or at least eventually you have to
use it so what am I going to do here I
want this thing sorry I've got the power
on the first time have a look at it and
have a look at how similar it is to this
object we've ended up with see how soon
there is what's the difference they're
not exactly the same that's the
difference the 3 and the 2 these are the
only differences okay and they're just a
constant coefficient so this is fine I
can deal with this if I want something
that's like the integral of this then
all I'm gonna do we're gonna rewrite
this on the left hand side is I'm going
to treat this like an equation and just
like since you seven when you first met
them if you do one something to one side
of the equation you just do it together
if you multiply by two or you add one or
you take logs of both sides I can
integrate both sides okay so I'm just
going to write it just the way you see
it now there is everything that was on
the left hand side before the derivative
of this I am integrating but well what
variable should I integrate with respect
to not a trick question have a look the
only variable I have is X's so I'm gonna
integrate with respect to X is that okay
on the right hand side I'm also going to
integrate and I have to do it just the
same way I did on the left so I'm going
to get this
that look you okay all right
now have a look at the left-hand side
you're differentiating and then you're
also integrating at the same time this
is a little bit like doubling something
and then having it with a subtle
difference I should end up back where I
started
yeah I should end up back where I
started but it's not quite like doubling
and halving which gives you back exactly
what you started with when you integrate
and you have an indefinite integral
something else comes along for the ride
why does this appear mysteriously think
about it the reason it appears is
because any of these guys like this guy
or like this guy or like this guy
any of them could differentiate to get
back to here okay so therefore in this
case you don't necessarily get back to
that one you get back to him or any of
his buddies does that make sense so I've
integrated on the left-hand side okay on
the right-hand side by I'm going to take
that three over two at the front it's
just the constant coefficient yeah
okay you're right with that does it look
okay I haven't done anything too
dramatic
now I'm so close to getting my answer so
close have a look back at what we wanted
and have a look at what we've got
what's the difference it's just the
three over two now I don't want the
three over to there so can you tell me
what operation I can do that will get
rid of the three over two I could just
divide both sides by three over two if
there was a five there I'd divide both
sides by five or if there was whatever
right so if I am dividing by three over
two fractions I'm gonna multiply by
something instead because my brain likes
multiplication better I'm gonna multiply
by two-thirds
it's a decay that will have the same
effect won't it I just did it to one
side so you better do it to the other
you care with that look all right cancel
cancel cancel cancel really this is it
right so I guess I should tidy
everything up the original question
integral of etc etcetera and then what
you end up with is this two-thirds
square root plus it okay now what do you
think how's your brain going we know how
to differentiate by doing this first
step you can integrate some things that
otherwise would be impractical work just
confusing okay and you will get this
style of question quite a bit now the
astute among you should notice I did
something slightly dodgy it's okay I'm
going to justify why in fact maybe you
can justify why it's okay but I wonder
if anyone spotted it it was on this line
this one here something was just
slightly off there's a reason why it's
okay but can you work out what's going
on like what do you say yeah so you
remember why did I multiply the
right-hand side by two and three why did
I do that because I didn't want the
three onto there so that's fine we know
what happened over there
and all of this thing that we multiply
is just one object no problem
but then I snuck it in over here I
didn't write it here
okay now you tell me why is it actually
okay this is actually literally the
answer you'll find for question six a in
this exercise why is it okay so yeah
this guy here right this guy here if you
wanted to be super ultra pedantic about
it see how it doesn't appear anywhere
and then suddenly that it's like a a
wild see up here okay you really should
say what it is so here it is the most
succinct way to introducing it is to
just say hey look see is not just a
random letter it's a real number this is
just a fancy set notation for saying
that if you wanted to be longer about it
you'd say where C is any real number
okay but two-thirds times a real number
it's still a real number so what I had
before still works just fine and this is
exactly what you'll see you don't need
to say two-thirds times C because that's
still see okay